on hopeful advice with Bobby Kalama at 7
inches of sticks and recourse for kalila
I am a 90 year old girl in Canada and I
have recently been diagnosed with
Asperger's it has been extremely hard to
wrap my head around it and to accept
I've always felt different but now I
feel like I have a huge label across my
head saying autistic having Asperger's
helps me realize why I've never been
good at making connections to other
people that being said I have never had
any romantic connections just from the
lack of social skills and extreme social
anxiety my question is how should I go
about getting out there in the dating
world
I feel so behind of all my peers in this
aspect and other aspects in life and if
when do I start dating how and when do I
go about the subject of my diagnosis my
name is Anna how old she is I wasn't
aware that Asperger's were still a
diagnosis actually I thought it was just
stream spectrum yeah it can go from
anything from low function very
functional which are oh thank you a
little bit yeah are people who are
absolutely no communication skills at
all so it's a very she seems like she
and she's probably very bright yeah the
other respect the other side of the
spectrum is obviously the savants who
are I think the answer to anybody that's
like looking for some sort of romance
these days is online dating I just I
think that really is there's no stigma
to that anymore
in you know pictures you just got to put
yourself out there you have to make the
decision to get yourself out there and
that is the easiest way to get yourself
out there yeah and I don't think that
you should lead with that insecurity
there it is you have it you own it and
you know it doesn't define you
yeah it doesn't and it's it's it's not a
hindrance either it can be also if she
if I'm a kalila and she goes I have
Asperger's I go what is it and she'll
tell me I don't think that it would make
me feel weird I mean I have I times I do
think I fall under the spectrum I know a
lot of like I ticks and I blink
anxiously a lot I have severe I have
weird things about me and ticks
that I do I have tics too big okay okay
what's the other question okay so that's
we do and I like questions more so I'm
17 years old and I have herpes I don't
know how to deal with it any advice on
how to communicate with people that I
might be with in the future
what is herpes pretty sure you're
familiar yeah please don't say that
because then that she has it yeah you
know what I always say to girls can you
get more herpes yeah yeah can you I mean
you can have HSV one which is like not
the very obvious or painful reoccurring
once throughout your whole life that's
like the ones in your mouth but you can
also get down there they're not the the
outbreaks are not as like intense but
you know they have super aids but then
they have HSV to which really you've
heard of super super aids super I've
never heard of that yes is that real
yeah super AIDS I think I heard it well
HIV Jesus Christ but herpes you know who
doesn't have so brazen 8 out of 10
people by the time they're a certain age
probably have the virus inside of them
whether or not it chooses to you know
show itself make cell phone so yeah so
that's the distinction thank you what's
your name
are you a herpe harmonii yes Latino yeah
[Laughter]
you know on the herpe thing I mean
transparency is always 100% the best
policy in anything you'll ever come
along with in your life the conversation
of admittance will be much less
difficult than the conversation of
what's the word guilt yeah you know when
you when something was found out I mean
you just got to start with it and it's
it's super common like it's very common
and use protected you know you're gonna
protect yourself you're 17 don't know
that you should even be doing it yet
anyway leaving an honest live star is
always the like I said know a lot of
comics that [ __ ] around really they [ __ ]
around behind their wives back or
whatever and I I do say I go do it it's
gonna come back you gotta cut yeah I
don't know why you live like that and
you're in a lot of these guys are doing
well I always say you want to be the
Train excuse me I always say you want to
pull a train goddammit I always say you
want to be the engine on the train and
not the caboose I want to be driving the
situation and not being drug along in
the wake of it yeah so that that's a
good note to end on herpes yeah
[Music]